voici le nouveau les le plus célèbre de
la planète aujourd'hui le prince harry
et son épouse meghan markle ont présenté
leur fils au public et il s'appelle
hachey en fait son nom complet est archi
harrison man battle windsor le bébé se
portent à merveille le couple a par la
suite était présenté son petit archie à
son arrière grand mère la reine
elizabeth 2 sébastien ce petit archie il
a très très peu de chances de devenir
roi un jour c'est ça dans l'ordre de
succession au trône
il est 7e parce que mine de rien la
famille s'agrandit alors comment on
arrive à ce résultat
si vous voulez bien cours 101 de
monarchie britannique regarder ça au
sommet de l'arbre généalogique
évidemment c'est la reine elizabeth ii
sur le trône depuis 1952
c'est le règne doit-on de rappeler le
plus long de l'histoire britannique et
la 93 ans aujourd'hui et son mari
philippe philip mountbatten duc
d'edimbourg alors le couple a quatre
enfants
edward djouad est le plus connu bien sûr
le prince charles c'est l'aîné la raison
pour laquelle il est premier dans
l'ordre de succession au trône et la 78
aujourd'hui alors qu'il vient ensuite ce
sont ses deux fils william et harry
même logique la laine et passe devant il
en va de même pour les enfants de
l'année alors viennent ensuite le prince
george la princesse charlotte le prince
louis harry lui est 6e et c'est la
raison pour laquelle le petit archipel
hui et septième dans l'ordre de
succession entre alors parlons de ce
prénom archie un peu surprenant pour la
famille royale parce qu'il suggère une
certaine rupture avec la tradition
pourquoi les d'abord parce qu'en tant
que fils de dieu qu'ils auraient pu
recevoir les titres de comte de dôme
bolton ou encore s'appeler lord ko
tshibanda tine windsor il s'appelle
seulement archives jamais vu dans la
monarchie est bon archi on a dit
aujourd'hui ça veut dire authentique
audacieux brave harrison il aurait pu
s'inspirer également de ses grand pères
ou de ses arrière grands pères mais ça
veut dire ça oui vous voyez la logique
plus américain aussi c'est ce qu'on a
dit aujourd'hui alors à plusieurs égards
c'est une famille unique dans la
monarchie
merci beaucoup sébastien pour ce petit
coursan